in this video i'm going to show you how
to make a 2d photo look 3d
in after effects
[Music]
hey there my name is cameron with motion
science and in this video i'm going to
show you how to take a 2d photo and turn
it into a 3d masterpiece this is a
really great technique to use to spice
up your portfolio or any social media
post it's really easy to do and doesn't
require any third-party plug-ins so
let's jump in
so here we are in after effects
and the very first step in the process
is me pulling in different images that
i'm considering doing the parallax
effect on
and laying those images out to find a
good composition
once i find that composition i launch
photoshop
and i divide that image up into multiple
layers typically the foreground the
middle ground and the background i start
to cut out my layers so i'm focused on
the dude
here
to begin with so i'm using
uh the selection tool and
trying to get everything selected as
best as possible
in a quick manner
once i have that selected
i will start to
erase parts of the image i don't need
and then zoom in and really pay
attention to the details
it's all about the details when cutting
images out
especially things like in between
fingers here like we're seeing
here i'm zooming in
and
masking out
parts of the image i don't want to see
i'm an old school guy so i like to use
the pen tool a lot of times so here i am
using the pen tool to cut out the
skateboard
then i make the same selections again
select the background do some feathering
and do some content aware fill i'm not
going to go in deep into how you use
content aware fill
but you can see here sometimes it works
great
other times it's not so much
i'm not by any means a pro photoshop
user
i just know enough to get by and the
thing here is that this doesn't have to
be a perfect
fill
in the background we just have to cover
up enough of the edges
so that when we're doing the parallax
effect uh the effect we're trying to
pull off works
and a lot of times what i'll do is i'll
jump back and forth between after
effects and photoshop to clean up parts
of the edge that maybe
we're seeing that we shouldn't be seeing
and things like that
here i am
just focusing on the foot i might need
to have more information on this foot
than what we currently see so i'm trying
to
duplicate
the foreground foot and bring it into
the background foot and see if i can
kind of blend them together
i import my
photoshop layer in as a composition
retain layer sizes what i like to do now
is make these layers 3d and position
them in 3d space i like to keep an
original in the background so i can keep
track of the proportionate scale of the
image once i've got that set up i jump
back into my main composition and i add
a camera now i could add this camera to
the pre comp it's just the way i like to
work keep things simple with the camera
so i like to have a pre comp of all the
layers inside of it set up a basic
camera move and then go in and start
tweaking some of the moves of the camera
so you can see here i brought the camera
into the pre comp thinking maybe that'll
work better
and i realized that the background still
has the guy the dude in it so here i am
using content aware fill
to remove that guy so in this example
content aware fill works a little bit
better
jumping back into after effects again
working with keyframes just trying to
get that camera moved just right giving
a little bit of a push on that camera
move uh doing a vertical move
along with a little bit of a z move as
well
and then i'm starting to adjust the
skateboard to make it rotate a little
bit to give it a little bit more life
just get a little bit rotation i like to
reverse keyframes a lot of times so i'll
try rotating one way
then reversing that move see if it works
better it's also better to use less
values than more so for rotation i'm
using very small values rotation
again playing around more with the
camera move
just trying to see what works and what
doesn't work
and i like to continue to preview things
over and over again a lot of times i
like to let the
ram preview just run over and over again
as i'm looking at things and seeing what
i notice that that isn't necessarily
working
so now i'm trying to add a puppet tool
to the dude to see if i can make his
foot kind of
bend uh do a little bit of movement to
it and see how that works and it looks a
little bit funky a little bit you know
that's the thing with the puppet tool a
lot of times it can get a little bit
stretchy and yet be really careful with
it less is more always less is more so
that's kind of cool but it looks weird
because his two feet are moving together
the entire time and in reality they're
going to move probably a little bit
separately so
we're going to first focus in on
covering up the background a little bit
some of those imperfections by adding
camera depth of field i love depth of
field i use it in most of my work
adding some keyframes for depth of field
and kind of helps to hide things in the
background that we painted out
[Music]
so back in photoshop i'm going to
attempt to separate the foreground leg
from the background leg and i realize
there's a couple
errors here so i'm going to fill those
layers in and again this does not have
to be perfect right i see so many
artists focusing on having it just
perfect but we just need to focus on the
areas that the camera is going to see
and that's it so we're going to do the
least amount possible
i'm selecting this area here because we
need to content aware
fill this area
and again there'll be a leg in front of
this area so it's not
imperative that we get this absolutely
correct so i'm going to zoom in here
remove some of the areas sometimes i'll
use the pen tool for this sometimes i'll
use the
brush for this like you see here
but just getting rid of some of the
excess information that we don't need to
see
[Music]
then what i'm going to do is import
just the leg layers into my pre-comp i
have
line them up make sure that they're
scaled rotated correctly
and lined up with my original image like
we see here and then i'll focus on
animating them after i have that
[Music]
so now that they're lined up correctly i
can rotate that foreground leg just a
little differently with a little more
rotation value than the background and
it brings a whole lot of dimension to
this image as you can see here
i can also add some puppet tool
distortion to the foreground leg and
make it bend as well like we see here
it just adds that little extra detail
of movement that really sells this
parallax effect
and here i am reversing the keyframes
again i like to reverse things just to
see if they work better and reverse them
[Music]
until i get something that's just
feeling
nice
then i'm going to spend some time just
ram previewing
tweaking keyframes getting it just right
and i'm going to add a simple matte
choker to the skateboard so that i can
tighten up the edges and then i want to
add one more element to the scene which
is a lens flare to kind of bring
everything together
so i'm going to start here with the
trapcode drill lens flares per usual
with the trapcode effects i can't get
the presets to load so i delete that
and move on to the old tried and true
optical flares by video copilot
add the flare up in the left corner
and then realize that the light should
probably be coming from the opposite
direction
so i'm going to move that over to the
right side here and i'm just going to
have that lens flare just do a really
subtle move uh up and down that's all it
takes just to kind of sell that effect
of some light coming into the camera
[Music]
so i'm also going to add a little bit of
flicker here just to give the light a
little bit more movement the beams are a
little too artificial so i'm going to
add some gaussian blur
blur them out increase the blur
[Music]
doing a final ram preview here just to
check it out it's looking really
dope
and there we go there is a really
awesome
skateboarding parallax shot
i hope that you really enjoyed this
lesson as much as i loved teaching it so
please let me know if you have any
questions in the comments below i'd love
to answer them for you hit that like
button if you enjoyed this video and
please subscribe to this channel it
helps other people find this channel as
well if you're looking to upgrade your
design skill set master the art of style
and execute like a pro i have a course
called stylecraft that you can check out
at
motionscience.tv you can also learn more
about this course by clicking the link
in the description below as always
thanks for watching my name is cameron
and this is motion science
[Music]
you